you know maybe time has caught up with
snyder's vision for superheroes and just
living in the worst possible reality has
made his vision
suddenly seem light and fluffy by
comparison
doesn't look so dark now does it
[Music]
so after that shockingly cynical opening
gag
even for me i wanted to sort of
talk through my thoughts on the concept
not really the possibility i'll get to
that but the concept
of possibly continuing on with zack
snyder's
vision for dc films for the dc eu
which i will henceforth be referring to
as the snyder verse
so as has kind of been predicted
with the premiere of zack snyder's
justice league
there has been some call so far at least
not as loud as
it was for the snyder cut of justice
league but there has been some call
and some push or at least some inquiry
as to hey
this seemed to be okay and went down
well definitely better than the version
you released to theaters
could we maybe have the
films that this was supposed to lead
into
and i kind of want to talk through that
as an idea
from an artistic perspective from a
brand management perspective but before
i dive down this rabbit hole
this is a thought exercise i do not
believe
that we are going to see warner brothers
finance
the return of the snyder verse and
i am i'm almost certain about that i
have to stick it almost on there because
i was fairly certain we were never gonna
get the snyder cut but even taking that
into uh account
i do not think we're ever gonna see this
happen and i'll get into some of the
reasons towards the end
but here's the big one the snyder cut of
justice league was actually
a fairly low financial commitment for
warner brothers to make because most of
it was already shot they had to fund
reshoot and a bunch of
redos and expansions of effects work
and that was not exactly cheap about the
tune of 70 million dollars
but you add that to the cost of what
they
sank into justice league the first time
around and they
basically got a 400 million dollar movie
for 70 million dollars to release on
their platform that they're trying
desperately to
big up as much as possible right now it
made a lot of sense from a lot of
perspectives
now trying to take any of the things
that zack snyder's film was meant to set
up that seem to either have been
scrapped have since gone in a different
direction or are in some kind of
limbo things like the flash movie the
cyborg movie any kind of direct
continuation of justice league
that means paying for the entire cost of
that new movie up front
and given that warner brothers already
kind of
had to eat it on justice league
definitely and batman v superman while
not a flop
underperformed for what they had
projected and thought it was gonna make
i i have a hard time believing that they
throw that much more money at it
70 million throwing at the snyder cut
while not
um you know a drop in the bucket all
things considered
looking at it now and getting a proper
perspective of what it was that
everything was going on and knowing that
this was part of the intended push to
really
make hbo max more of a presence as a
streaming service
and knowing how much of a priority that
is for at t now that they own warner
brothers yeah
yeah that made a lot of sense but
taking it as a given that i do not
believe
anything that i'm about to talk about
will actually ever happen
let's talk about the artistic merit
and the sort of potential fallout
consequences would it be worth it
ideas of this so the first thing to
bring up is well what would immediately
follow on from this
because a couple of the things have in
fact happened
such as aquaman such as wonder woman
which has had its first
uh sequel that has already happened and
those
franchises have already started to
distance themselves
not necessarily from snyder's continuity
blatantly but uh definitely
distanced themselves from his tone and
mood and kind of struck out and did
their own things
and in the case of aquaman there are
legitimately continuity
uh issues between that and zack snyder's
justice league
uh so you know there's
there's that and then there's the stuff
that just hasn't happened yet there's
the flash movie that keeps changing
directors every other year and
never seems to move forward and i'm i'm
kind of going to be surprised if that
ever happens i think
if i were to guess i have no insider
knowledge
i should make that clear i don't have a
source so like don't think that
i know what's really going on but if i
were to guess
i would say they probably keep retooling
what it is
that the flash movie is intended to be
because originally
at its earliest conceptions it would
have just been
something to follow on from justice
league but then
once they realized that
batman v superman didn't go down as well
as they wanted and justice league
started to become
what it became in terms of of the
theatrical version
they started talking up flashpoint as if
they were going to use that
to serve as a kind of way to reboot
the universe except that then got
stalled and then
the aquaman and wonder woman movies just
moved forward without really
acknowledging justice league much at all
and seemed to be fine which made
the idea of a reboot and retooling
flashpoint style story may not even be
necessary anymore because the other
franchises are chugging along just fine
so then what do you even do at this
point
now they seem to still be holding on to
that but that keeps going back and forth
the idea of a cyborg movie seemed to
have been scrapped
almost immediately following
the release of justice league and since
i mentioned cyborg that kind of brings
up another thing
which factors in on snyder as well
will snyder and some of the people who
are kind of core to what it looked like
he was building
even be willing to come back
i mean one could say well sure snyder
would accept that
like look he came back to do justice
league because
warner brothers were the only people he
could work with if he was ever going to
get a chance to finish that it was their
movie
so he had to come back and work with
warner brothers but that relationship
seems really
splintered after the events of the
justice league filming
and i don't want to delve too much into
sort of trying to figure that out
because there are conflicting reports
about
how much did snyder's leaving to
mourn the loss of his daughter how much
of that was just an excuse that warner
brothers really were happy to have to
boot him
uh or you know they and we don't really
know for certain but there does seem to
have been a splintering of that
relationship because they were already
moving forward the dc eu as much as
possible
without snyder and snyder for the first
time in a long time made a film
without them because he's got um the
army of the dead i think is the one the
zombie film is coming out on netflix
he's been at warner brothers for a while
so for him to leave them to do a movie
somewhere else
that doesn't bode too well with the idea
that he's willing to come back and work
with him again
after what's gone on with with justice
league mainly
and even if he was willing
i think he he has to know by now
that even with the snyder cut released
and better received
they're still not going to grant him
that level of control on a theatrically
released film the only reason they did
for snyder cut is because
well that's what they bought they they
were paying for
and selling the snyder cut if they
didn't give him full control then there
was no point in doing any of it
but what snyder does
is expensive his approach is expensive
though
these movies are expensive anyways and
to sink a lot of money in that when at
least as far as the kind of numbers and
returns and critical reception that
warner brothers wanted
they've already seen it fail let's say
two and a half times uh you know
the very middling response on man of
steel the
uh very hotly contested response to
batman v superman and then
give him a half uh credit for the
original theatrical release of
justice league i i can't imagine that
they would
spring for it it it would be an
odd choice the other thing is
you know i mentioned zack snyder like
maybe maybe he could be convinced to
come back
i think the bigger issue would be ray
fisher
who played cyborg because
he obviously clashed at this point very
publicly
with not only joss whedon who seems to
be the only one who's really meeting out
a lot of consequences
uh from that and plus you know other
things that people have
come forward to talk about but fisher
has
said flat out he will not come back
and work for warner brothers as long as
walter hamada is still there now walter
hamada is a studio head
um kind of i don't think he's really
equivalent to kevin feige but he's one
of the big
people at this at the high end executive
studio level
who was in charge of the dc eu and
ray fisher i would say not wrongly holds
hamada responsible for the fact
that whedon was allowed
to behave and treat fisher the onset the
way that he
did he saw a walter hamada as
enabling and empowering the behavior
that he was speaking
that he later came forward and spoke out
against
and there's no indication that warner
brothers is going to get rid of walter
hamada and i don't think they would just
to bring back
who is up to this point a supporting
player in an alternate cut
of a movie where he looks much better
and a supporting actor
in a tanked version earlier of that
movie and i definitely don't see them
giving him
his own film and then the question
becomes
would snyder be willing to work under
circumstances where he wouldn't get ray
fisher who obviously
still wanted to work with in the flash
forward thing in the in
zack snyder's justice league he's one of
the superheroes still alive so clearly
the intention was
to keep doing more things with him so
that becomes another complication even
if you get snyder back
and give him the control
are you going to be willing to fire
one of your major executives for the
sake of bringing back an actor that
snyder clearly wanted to work with
i don't see that happening and i do
honestly think that ray fisher
will put his foot down and will hold to
that line because at this point for the
kind of
like he has taken on goliath for this he
seemed to be perfectly willing he seemed
to have accepted
publicly that he was tanking his career
speaking out against joss whedon
and walter hamada um amongst others
so if he was already willing to accept
that as the possible outcome
of speaking out when he did in the first
place i can't imagine he's gonna bend
at a later point i mean it's not
impossible but
he doesn't strike me like he's going to
so there's a whole
bunch of beyond just the cost of it of
just logistical
people management of trying to get any
of this made and then there's the
question of
what about the franchises that have
continued forward
without snyder's influence like aquaman
which is going to be getting its sequel
which is not uncontroversial but that's
related to amber heard i've talked about
that before
so like but that's moving forward in its
own direction doing its own thing
as is wonder woman at this point though
with the reception of wonder woman 1984
being
mixed at best uh that that might be a
little more uncertain now but
they the people at the top seem content
to let these start to become their own
things and
that i think is the biggest issue
when snyder was building this in the
first place
it was on the presumption that he would
be shaping
this entire thing which
was a gamble that ultimately didn't pay
off and it is a gamble worth comparing
to what
marvel does because it's worth
remembering that
marvel has had underperforming films and
in fact has had some
very early in its life cycle nobody
really talks about
the incredible hulk movie with edward
norton anymore
and it it wasn't a flop but it didn't do
great
there are have been other things thor
the dark world that have hiccuped along
the way
but it's never caused the entire thing
to collapse
because marvel has never been dependent
on a singular vision for the entire
thing
they have for certain individual
franchises see james gunn
and guardians of the galaxy but not for
the entire apparatus which is why
like some people have asked in regards
to joss whedon since i've had to bring
him up anyways
you know why are we talking about
whether or not
uh we it's still okay to consume things
like buffy the vampire slayer firefly
dollhouse angel but not so much talking
about the mcu
because you know he directed the first
two avengers films and he did
but he wasn't the sole voice
or even the primary driving force behind
the franchise like maybe for
a couple of movies he was but then he
he burned out and he left and marvel
seemed to have learned right then was
like okay
we we have we have um kevin feige
to oversee and keep this we don't need
the director
of a specific franchise to be setting
the tone for everything
which makes everything much more
self-contained
and much less likely to fall apart just
because
of one franchise tanking or one
director's vision
bottoming out whereas dc
really put all their eggs in the zack
snyder basket at first which was why
things were such a jumbled mess
initially
and you can even look at something like
suicide squad which snyder did not
direct
but very much seemed to have been made
with the
deliberate intent to fit into the darker
grittier desaturated violent world
that snyder had created whereas
stuff that's gone on since then like
definitely something like shazam
almost feels like it is uh refuting
a lot of that atmosphere and that's the
kind of stuff that has come about
after snyder has been away and not
touching any of this stuff so the
question becomes
if you were to let him come back and
start
rebuilding the snyder verse
do you forcibly wrench all the other
franchises that have been starting to go
out in their own directions
back into line with what he would have
had them
be if he had still been at the helm of
this whole thing from a creative
standpoint
or do you just not allow him to have
access to the things that have gone off
and done their own thing like you don't
let him mess with wonder woman you don't
let him mess with aquaman you don't let
him touch shazam
and you're like okay look you can have
superman you can have batman
uh you can have flash have uh
have cyborg but leave the rest of these
alone well
but then are you really reinstating the
snyder verse because you'd be
imposing a whole bunch of restrictions
that wouldn't be there in the first
place
something's gotta give and it also made
me think about my own reaction
to zack snyder's justice league because
i
liked it quite a bit more than i would
have thought
actually possibly more than any other
movies made
sans 300 but
i realized afterwards and actually
after even i shot my review so i didn't
even mention this
there um though you still check that out
um part of why
i took to this as well as i did
was because i knew it wasn't setting the
tone
for what was going to come part of what
was so
soul-crushing for me about a movie like
batman be superman
aside from its own issues which i think
it has plenty
but it wasn't what i wanted
to keep seeing
whereas zack snyder's justice league
i was able to treat as this is not
something that i'm going to watch
and then no every other dc movie will be
like this
this is something i'm going to watch as
an
alternate version as an out of
continuity
take and i can be way more accepting
of things that i don't necessarily agree
with or think are good for these
characters or this world or what or the
genre as a whole
if i know that that film is
not going to be the template on which a
bunch of future stuff is being built
had the zack snyder version of justice
league been released to theaters and i
mentioned in that review
it was never going to be not in the
state we saw it four hours are you
kidding me no that was never gonna
happen
but just for a second let's say that it
was
i would not have liked it nearly as much
as i did watching it on hbo max
if only for the fact that i would have
gone oh
god everything in the dceu is going to
be like this
and not because it's bad but because
it's not what i
want to be the standard that's not
what i want the baseline of these movies
to be
speaking for myself so
that then begs the question
what if the snyder verse was just an hbo
max
thing what if it was kind of its own
continuity and you're not releasing it
to theaters where it's going to confuse
you know your average moviegoers who are
wondering well we have robert pattinson
in the batman and we've got ben affleck
in
you know saying that he's saying to the
joker
i will kill you yeah is this the same
guy what is going on
you if you were to restrict it to the
premium service
would that make more sense yes but then
we bump into the
realistic expense issue again which is
again looking at zack snyder's justice
league
they basically got a 400 million dollar
movie for 70 million dollars
so to spend that kind of money
like i mentioned at the front end i
don't think they would
they would think it'd be worth it in a
theatrical release
to spend the kind of money that from
that would allow snyder from the ground
up
to start continuing his ideas
they're definitely not going to spend
that on just the streaming service
because as much as the streaming service
is very important
right now it
it you still have to have the book's
balance
and this
a lot of what i'm saying about what will
or won't happen
the thing is there's one major x factor
in all of this that makes it harder to
predict than it should be
which is a t because
a t buying warner brothers changes
the priorities because warner brothers
could have been looking at things from a
more long-term sustained viability
perspective
but the way corporate consolidation
works and especially for something as
big as a t
buying warner brothers and for them
you know the dc stuff is just a sliver
of that
they care about what you add to the
portfolio right now
sustainability they care about
sustainability on the grand
scale of their entire company they don't
really care if a specific division
is sustainable long term if it's not
they'll just cut it
so knowing that or at least knowing
that's a possibility and not knowing
exactly where 18d is places priorities
its priorities are definitely not with
the publishing arm of dc which they
gutted did a video on that back when
that happened
so it really does become
more difficult because i can
i can make what i think are reasonably
decent guesses at what these studios
would do
if they did not have a bigger entity
breathing down their neck and scouring
their books
but they do and that makes things
a little bit harder depending on what
the priorities of the bigger company are
but pulling things back
to the main sort of
franchise management reason why i don't
think it's
a good idea beyond just the viability
but i don't think it's ultimately a good
idea to try and bring back the snyder
verse
and this is not a judgment on what the
quality of it would have been although
full disclosure i probably wouldn't
enjoy it that much but i'm trying not to
let that clap my judgment
is that too much has changed since
snyder left justice league warner
brothers had its period of scrambling
trying to figure out what it was going
to do
and the closest thing that it's got to
figuring out what to do was to just
treat each of these things separately
because like i said when they put all
their eggs in the snyder basket
the whole thing felt like it was falling
apart
but when they got wonder woman
established as its own thing
and shazam was pretty much a
self-contained thing
and aquaman was pretty much a
self-contained thing
and everyone's super excited for the
suicide squad which
does not fit the tone and the vibe
of the zack snyder version of these
characters in this world
and you had birds of prey and and warner
brothers does seem
to really be happy to continue to bank
and throw basically throw harley quinn
at the wall in as many projects as
possible
and just hope that it sticks and she's
honestly
been better received as light and funny
and not angsty i don't think there's a
place to reinsert
snyder at the head of all this
without basically throwing all the rest
of that out
and i don't think that would be worth it
not from a business
standpoint not really from an artistic
standpoint
here's what i would be curious to see
and what i would kind of like to see
if snyder is willing
i would happily
read a graphic novel
of whatever his follow-up to justice
league was going to be
i would be more than happy to get a
sense of what he wanted to do
because like i said his version of
justice league went down much better for
me than i expected it to
even with you know the caveats that i
said that i got to treat it like in
elseworlds
and i am curious what else he was going
to do
but i don't expect to ever be able to
see it on
film and i'm not sure it would be good
for the
franchise as a whole for it
to happen because marvel has certainly
shown you get away with interconnecting
these things and having a sprawling
continuity
but dc's own success with its individual
franchises
in the wake of batman v superman and
justice league
has also shown that
they can have success treating these as
their
own thing and not worrying about the
continuity
because aquaman made over a billion
dollars
and there weren't and there are
complaints to be had about that film but
they weren't along the lines of
why weren't there more nods to the main
continuity
it didn't need them nor did wonder woman
nor did shazam and
we're getting good products
just by not worrying about it and that
could be enough
to distinguish it more from marvel hey
is that continuity laden mess where if
you missed the last few films you feel
like you don't know what the heck is
going on
too much oh sorry to hear that
here's a suicide squad movie where you
don't really need to have seen all the
previous stuff it stands on its own have
fun
that could be the way in which dc is the
alternative
to marvel as opposed to being darker
and grittier and having batman
say he's gonna kill the joker
because i'm not sure how
artistically financially long-term
viable that is ultimately
the main thing that sells reliably is a
quality product well made
not always selling as well as it should
unfortunately but
you're gonna be on much better standing
if you just make good stuff
and with his version of justice league i
do think snyder did actually make a
pretty good thing but people have also
been making good stuff
in the dceu completely absent his
influence
i think that might be the best way to
move forward
so those are my rambling thoughts on the
concept of bringing back the snyder
verse
what do you think about all this were
you even able to follow my train of
thought
i don't know i don't know if i can
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down the comments let's talk
about it
i have a patreon hopefully there'll be a
link up there
if not it's down in the description
because youtube is broken
and doesn't pay my bills patreon pays my
bills
and i i do like to eat
but um don't worry too much about it
if you're not able to there are perks as
well
for youtube memberships that helps me
too but even if you can't do that the
lights this year's subscribes
those help me out also but you don't
even have to worry about that
because at the end of the day you are
the council
i'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you